here to react Michael Knowles host of
the Michael no show no no show good
morning how are you good to see you
great thanks for being here so tell us
about this kind of buried lead of the
Podesta group being involved with Manta
fort well as you know being a Democrat
means never having to say that you're
sorry
for months now president Trump has
referred to this investigation as a
rigged witch hunt and the special
counsel seems determined to prove him
correct Paul Manafort pled guilty to
unregistered lobbying for foreign
governments six years ago as you say
Democrats super lobbyists Tony Podesta
did precisely the same thing also in
there is former Obama White House
Counsel Gregory Craig same thing at the
same time the same exact crime and yet
right now Podesta and Craig are walking
free while Paul Manafort has had the
book thrown at him and faces the very
real possibility of dying in prison and
why is that it's because yes I'm sorry
go ahead
no you're right and you can completely
stop it I'm wondering also you're right
because metaphor does I recall the FBI
went into his home in Virginia like five
or six in the morning his wife still in
a nightgown upstairs you know ready to
seize computers files evidence whatever
we haven't heard a single time that
they'd have done anything like that with
Greg Craig Tony Podesta and I'm not
advocating it but why do they do that to
Paul Manafort
and none of the Democratic lobbyists we
haven't heard about them being squeezed
well of course it's because Paul manna
for its real crime is not unregistered
lobbying it's not misleading federal
investigators like Tony Podesta has done
the brother of Hillary Clinton's
campaign chairman it's because Paul man
affords real crime is committing the
unforgivable sin of working for
president Trump and it lends credibility
to a widely held perception that this
investigation is not an honest
undertaking of justice but rather a
partisan attack to undo a duly elected
president how does the media continue
then to peddle the same narrative that
the walls are closing in when anyone
who's serious or thoughtful looks at
this and says its exact opposite the
walls are crumbling it they don't have
anything here it seems that they have
absolutely nothing George papadopolis
will go to jail for 14 days thank
heavens our streets are finally safe and
what this is all about is not actually
about grabbing criminals or finding
boris and natasha around the corner in
russia collusion what it's about is
creating an air of collusion an air of
crime before the midterm elections this
timing is very convenient for Democrats
and it really causes people who want
this investigation to be about the
simple carriage of justice and being
finished up in due time it causes all of
us to raise our eyebrows at all of the
timing Oh Michael Knowles from the
Michael Nolt show thank you so much for
detailing the other side of the story
it's Russian Michael most famously wrote
a good reasons to vote for Democrats it
was full of black pages it's kind of
like Bob Muller has right now Michael
thank you very much appreciate it
Pete read that book over to see it it's
the only way I've read covers even
better than picture books